what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones season
7 episode 4 update video earlier today
HBO released ten new photos taking
during the filming of Episode four so
what I want to do is take a closer look
at them and see what else may be
happening in the upcoming episode so
let's get started in the first image we
can see Jon Snow Davos missandei Varys
Tyrion and Daenerys Targaryen standing
on the beach of Dragonstone and they are
all looking in the same direction they
are most likely watching someone arrive
on the beach and there are a few
different characters I believe they
could be looking at in the preview
trailer for episode 4 we saw Theon
Greyjoy arriving on this beach finally
making it back after being attacked by
his uncle Euron Greyjoy
in the second episode they could all be
standing here as Theon makes it to the
shore but there are someone else I think
they might be watching arrive as well in
the last episode we learned that Jorah
Mormont is now completely cured of his
greyscale thanks to Samwell Tarly Jorah
was told he was cleared to lead the
Citadel because he had no other signs of
greyscale so now that Jorah is free to
go he will probably head straight for
Dragonstone to reconnect with his
Khaleesi back in season six he revealed
to the nurse that he did have greyscale
and she told him to go get himself cured
then come back to her because she did
want him at her side when she was in
Westeros well I command you to find the
cure wherever it is in this world
I command you to heal yourself
and then we can't
when I take the second Kingdom I need
you by my and when I look at this new
photo of the group standing here
Daenerys is standing in the front of
this group and I think that's because
she wants to greet this person first and
I think it could be because it's Jorah
Mormont but she doesn't look very happy
either so that's why I think it might be
Theon also I'm split down the middle one
who this could be but let's take a look
at the next one in this next image Theon
Greyjoy is arriving on the beach and
there is a very good chance that
Daenerys and company are standing here
out of frame waiting for him to tell
them what the hell just happened we all
know Jon Snow is going to be wanting to
speak to Theon also so this should get
pretty interesting in the next photo
there is a close-up of Theon on this
beach and he might be telling Daenerys
everything that happened when he was
attacked by his uncle or this could be
when Jon Snow confronts Theon about the
things that he did while John was
actually in the Nights Watch Robb Stark
sent Theon to go greet with his father
who he hadn't seen since he was a child
and Robb Stark was hoping that he could
use the Greyjoy fleet but Balin wanted
nothing to do with that so instead of
fian going back with Robb he actually
burned the letter and he ended up
attacking Winterfell and holding
everyone there captive Theon also burnt
two farm boys while he was there any
beheaded sir Roderick which was one of
Ned Stark's closest friend so Jon Snow
is definitely going to want to confront
him about those things but since Theon
saved sons a Jon will probably let him
go with just a warning the next photo is
what Jaime and Bronn and they're both
looking in the same direction also and
it appears they're looking up into the
sky a bit I think they could be looking
at one of Danny's dragons as it comes
through the clouds and prepares to turn
the battlefield into the field of fire
as the Lannister and the Tarly troops
march back from Highgarden with all the
tyrell gold this will be the main event
in the next episode and there will be a
lot of casualties of war during this
battle scene the Lannisters and tarly's
will be mostly burnt alive and
slaughtered by the Dothraki men but I
think Daenerys is going to lose a lot of
soldiers too because the Lannisters are
just going to lay down and allow this to
happen although it is going to be pretty
damn hard to stop the dragon I believe
they will try to kill her dragon but
it's not going to be easy this battle
should be a lot of fun too
watch in the next image we can see songs
a stark out on the godswood again and
she looks like she was just spooked
again she could be out here with brain
perhaps he is telling her some more
things that he has seen bran could be
telling her some of Littlefinger secrets
or he could be telling her something
about Jon Snow you never really know
this could also be when her sister Arya
Stark arrives in the preview trailer we
did see Arya sitting on her horse
overlooking Winterfell Arya will be
making it inside of Winterfell in
Episode four and this might be when
Sansa receives word that her sister is
alive and she is at the gates coming in
there is another image that was released
online today and it showed Arya actually
standing inside of Winterfell courtyard
now I can't show you the picture of Arya
actually standing inside of Winterfell
because the company that released that
image has actually been giving channels
copyright strikes for showing their
stuff and I don't want to risk getting
one but hopefully all of you can just
take my word for this Arya will be
standing inside of Winterfell walls in
episode 4 but let's go to the next image
and this might even further confirm that
Arya Stark is going to arrive in this
photo we can see Brienne and Podrick
standing in the courtyard at Winterfell
and they are both looking at someone or
something
Podrick appears to have a little bit of
a smirk on his face so he might be
recognizing someone Brienne and Podrick
did meet Arya back in season 4 when
Brienne and the Hound got into that
fight you really stood I asked if you
wanted something I thought your mother
was bringing hunter
my mother's dead no I wish I could have
been there to protect her you're not a
northerner
I swore a sacred vow to protect so they
would recognize Arya when she makes it
to the gate and I think that's who
they're looking at and they're probably
happy to see her home and alive in the
next image we can see Littlefinger
overlooking the courtyard also and you
might be looking at the same thing
Littlefinger might start to get worried
now that he's being surrounded by the
wolves and Arya is the most vicious of
them all it might be the downfall of
Littlefinger the lone wolves are finally
becoming a pack again and Littlefinger
is going to start to sense that arya
coming home will be the game changer
they could seal Littlefinger's fate but
let's move on to the next one in this
image Cersei Lannister is meeting with
taiko who is there on behalf of the iron
bank and we saw a clip from this in the
preview trailer also Cersei was telling
him her plan about securing the Seven
Kingdoms and its people under her ruling
she wants to let him know that he has
nothing to worry about the money that
they owe the bank is on its way from
Highgarden as they speak and she thinks
the debt that the crown has owed for
years will be paid off in no time but
little does she know a very pissed-off
dragon queen is heading their way
looking for a little bit of payback from
the few losses that she has taken this
season already
the iron bank probably won't be
receiving the payment anytime soon and
once again Cersei will receive another
overdraft fee keeping her in debt and
putting the iron bank one step closer to
supporting her enemies the second half
of this season should get interesting
with the power starting to shift to
Daenerys aside in speaking of Daenerys
she's in the next photo with missandei
at her side and Jon Snow looking up at
them and it appears that Daenerys
emma-san they are discussing something
before they meet with Jon Snow on the
beach this could be right before they go
into the caves to look for a dragon
glass or before they meet with Theon or
possibly even Jorah Mormont on the beach
there is another photo that HBO released
and it's just a different angle of
Daenerys and missandei speaking right
here missandei does have a smile on her
face so it could be some gossiping about
her and grey worm or possibly even Jon
Snow I'm not going to call this pillow
talk I'm going to call this pillar talk
as in stones and pillars
missandei maybe smiling as she tells her
about what her and grey worm did or she
could be telling Daenerys that she
thinks Jon Snow likes her
missandei could say something like I saw
Jon Snow's staring at you my queen
something along those lines and Daenerys
is like really I've never tasted
direwolf before I'm just kidding but
comment down below and let me know what
you think is going on in these new
images they were all from episode 4 so
we are going to find out soon enough if
you think something else has taken place
and the images put it down below I want
to thank you all for stopping by for
this quick update video I've been
working on something else that I'm going
to release either tomorrow or Friday at
the latest so keep your eyes open for
that one and I also want to thank my
patreon supporters as well a lot of you
have been joining me on patreon so I
just want to let all you new members
know that I really do appreciate that
have a good day and I'll see you down in
the comment section bye
[Music]